[Music]
Nigeria's military spokesman has
announced a new prime minister Ali La
mean Zane served as the economy and
Finance Minister for eight years from
2002. meantime the West African Bloc
ecowas says it will hold a summit to
discuss the crisis in Niger on Thursday
and Nigeria's military has closed off
its airspace warning that any foreign
aggression will be met with Force fedul
abdarazik reports from Nema
this tightened Security on the streets
of Nigeria's capital nyame
West Africa negotiators are due to meet
after rejecting the military coup and
the suspension of Nigeria's Constitution
earlier the regional block Echo was
threatened to use Force to reinstate
ousted president Muhammad bazoom
supporters of the military Council back
the changes they say Army leaders have
liberated the country from Western
Powers especially the former Colonial
ruler France
today our country needs Liberation at
the moment some regions are facing
terrorism in a large way which prompted
people to leave therefore I appeal to
all young people to join us
Nigeria's military console insists it
has popular support
but critics say the Army leaders are
using mercenaries from the Russian
Wagner group to consolidate power
opposition parties and political figures
have urged the military Council to
organize presidential elections swiftly
while the ruling party and its
supporters are demanding the immediate
return of president bazoom to power even
if it requires the use of force
the ruling party wants to use the
closure of the borders and Western
pressure to reinstate the legitimate
regime
ordinary Nigerians are hoping Western
sanctions and the suspension of Aid will
not harm the economy
people struggling to make a living want
Niger to avoid turmoil they hope for an
end to the conflict even after the
military Council shut down Nigeria's
airspace
a top U.S state Department official is
in Niger but Victoria Newland was unable
to meet the self-proclaimed president
and the deposed president Muhammad
bazoom she advertising reports now from
Washington
Victoria Newland briefed reporters over
the phone just before she left for the
airport she said the conversations had
been at times difficult but she wanted
to make clear what was at stake if
democracy was not restored she'd asked
for gestures of the Health and Welfare
of the deposed president bazoom and she
hopes the people responsible will come
back to those requests she tells
reporters however she kept emphasizing
that the door was open for further
negotiations she said I they have their
own ideas talking about the coup leaders
their own ideas about how this goes
forward they do not have ideas that
comport with the Constitution and that
will be difficult in terms of how the
US's relationship if that's the path
they take newlyn said but we gave them a
number of options to take up on it the
U.S continuing to emphasize the need for
dialogue even as they have yet to
officially designate this a coup in
related news though the state department
did confirm that already hundreds of
millions of dollars what it called Aid
had already been suspended even before
that official coup designation
Al Jazeera Washington
well Al jazeera's Rosalind Jordan has
spoken to U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken who stopped short of calling the
situation in Niger a coup
very quickly sir the situation in Niger
will the U.S say this is now a coup
so whatever you call it what we've seen
is the disruption of the Constitutional
order in Niger and we like many
countries throughout Africa and notably
ecowas which brings together many
countries in in West Africa is
determined that the Constitutional order
be re-established that's what everyone's
focused on right now so
from our perspective for the United
States I've been in close contact with
president bazoom with many leaders
throughout Africa and everyone is
working toward the same objective the
restoration of the Constitutional order
and delegations from Mali and Burkina
faso's militaries are in niger's capital
Nema to meet coup leaders the West
African block ecowas has imposed
sanctions and warned it would send
troops to reinstate ousted president
Muhammad bazoom but an ultimatum to
reinstall the deposed government has now
passed and the Junta remains defiant
Mali and Burkina Faso have said they
would consider an attack on Niger a
declaration of war